hello and welcome to the point on this
week's show we'll be talking about
magazine cover discs there'll be a
little bit of playstation 1 nostalgia
and at one stage i'll make a bestiality
joke this concludes our demo to watch
the full version please send five
dollars to danny and andy's piss up fund
care of cbs interactive
san francisco california here is five
dollars enough ten
ten make it yeah ten dollars
ten bucks there was a time before the
internet got fast when you'd have to
decide between spending 30 minutes
downloading a single corn mp3 or a low
resolution mpeg of a dude banging a
donkey
a simpler time before software was
easily downloadable via the internet
before consoles even knew what a modem
was this was the golden age of the game
demo vertical slices of upcoming games
the developers released weeks before the
game's launch in an effort to drum up
hype these demos were shareware around
between friends or contained on cover
disks stuck to the front of magazines
for most gamers they were the first time
they really got to see a game in action
after months or years of flicking
through pages of screenshots a good demo
had the power to turn apathy into a sail
to start a groundswell of hype that
could make or break a game
demos were moments in time for gamers
and even today those of us who are
playing games back then can remember our
favorite demos i remember running into
my local news agent to grab a copy of
official playstation magazine the month
they had the incredible metal gear solid
demo on it it contained the first three
areas of the game and it was so
incredibly replayable that by the time
metal gear solid hit store shelves he
probably clocked off about 10 errors
playing the demo everyone i knew that
had a playstation had played that demo
and eventually bought the game how much
that demo helped sales as anyone's guess
but i'd hazard quite a lot in fact it
was so popular i'm pretty sure half of
the sales for zone of the enders on
playstation 2 were from people trying to
get access to the metal gear solid 2
demo that was bundled in that box so
it's fair to say hideo kashima is pretty
good at making a demo in fact he's so
good he tricked a bunch of us into
spending 30 bucks for one earlier this
year
for all intents and purposes grand
zeroes is a demo at least in terms of
the lofty expectations that mgs demos
have set it's a slice albeit a unique
one of what we should expect to play
when phantom pain comes out sometime in
the future you can complete all of its
modes in a couple of hours but it's
pretty replayable you know like a demo
now i don't mind paying for ground
zeroes but there's no way i was going to
do it 10 years ago and unlike the demo
there's probably no chance that anyone
stumbled onto playing ground zeroes this
was a game made specifically for fans of
the series with massive snake boners and
30 dollars to spare but that's not to
say that there aren't other ways we get
to play games before they're released in
fact if anything there are far more ways
now
if you pre-ordered destiny you probably
played the beta this week that's
basically a demo if you've ever
supported a kickstarter the chances are
you've been involved in an alpha the
entire early access section of steam is
full of truncated versions of games that
you pay to play and if that doesn't
appeal to you [__] it there are dozens
of free to play games out there and some
of them are like really really really
good demos for games are practically
dead they're basically dead on pc and
though next gen consoles have some
available clearly they're just a few
steps behind the early access revolution
the way we consume game media and the
way we actually get access to games has
fundamentally changed since the golden
age of the game demo but in that
transition we've definitely lost
something demo discs like early access
or betas were just a chance for you to
play your most anticipated game early
but more than that they were like a
tasting platter a disc had any mixture
of games ones you were interested in and
probably a bunch that you weren't but
demos were so short that you felt
encouraged to at least give them a go
this meant that you were exposed to
genres in series that you might not
necessarily have gone out of your way to
play pre-order betas and early access
are fantastic ways to get games in
people's hands to ground expectations
set by marketing to allow people to
communicate with developers but by their
very nature they are a transaction cash
is involved and when was the last time
you spent cash on something you didn't
think you wanted when i think about all
the wonderful demos i played even in
this past generation games like dead
rising bioshock just cause lost planets
skate so many of these are new ip that i
might not have been willing to take a
chance on as a full price game i
certainly wouldn't have wanted to play
any of these in early access so as much
as i enjoy the benefits of early access
and betas it does little to expand our
gaming horizons it's just like buying
into a demo of a game before it comes
out it's another form of marketing and
though a trusted recommendation from a
friend or stranger might get you to play
a wonderful game on early access with
the death of demos be them physical or
digital we've lost much of the ability
to discover new gaming experiences for
ourselves at least without paying a
small fortune hey or maybe i'm just an
old fuddy duddy who misses the feeling
of ripping a cd off the cover of a
magazine popping it in my computer and
seeing what mysteries lie within
look at this the team got a demo let's
get it
official playstation
demo disc world soccer winning 11 sevens
on it oh my god harry potter quidditch
world cup
ghost recon
jungle storm unlock videos maybe he's
got trailers on these things oh there's
a metal gear solid thing right there
i love this stuff look this is a jean
renault
interview okay
the [__] gillian anderson what
what is this is this like a section
about
so i don't know man this is great look
at this final fantasy
scigirls more like scigirls
that's pretty good
you